you may remember barack obama he was uh
the two-term president before orange man
and he was this guy who came in and it
was hope and it was change and it was
very exciting and then obviously
if you flash forward to where we're at
now where we live in a systemically
racist patriarchal society and
capitalism is evil and all of these
things uh he failed miserably his his
eight years in the oval office were
obviously a complete disaster uh i will
say this i voted for barack obama twice
now you guys all know about my political
evolution i was a lefty at the time
there's no doubt about it i did vote for
him both times it is worth noting that
the first time that barack obama ran for
president he was against gay marriage so
barack obama is a homophobe he has an
irrational fear of gay people he did not
want two men or two women uh to be able
to engage in the same sort of
relationship that a heterosexual couple
could now i suppose he did you know
evolve a little bit later but you know
the truth is that in his heart he
obviously hates gay people um and here
he is now barack obama who again didn't
solve any of the things that he set out
to do right because if he did then we
would have never got donald trump and
certainly we wouldn't needed joe biden
who was his vp to come in and fix all of
that right if barack obama had actually
accomplished all the wonderful hope and
change that he had promised
well now he is campaigning in this
virginia gubernatorial race
and just listen to him and i would only
add one other thing which is that during
uh the recall here in california obama
cut an ad that was pro-newsome that was
a complete fear-mongering scare monger
scare tactic ad we played it on the show
uh refused to even say larry elder's
name and congratulations it did work
here in california but here's obama and
you just tell me well you well that play
it why is it republicans don't want you
to vote
what what is it that they're so afraid
of
yeah you know it
it
i would assume terry if if they think
they've got better ideas why don't they
just go make the case
[Applause]
tell us your ideas
tell us why you think they're going to
be better tell us how it's going to help
that man get a job or or help that young
person go to college or help that person
get a trade
hey just explain it and if if you've got
good ideas
people will flock to your ideas but but
that's not what they try to do instead
you're trying to rig elections
because the truth is people disagree
with your ideas
and when that doesn't work
you start fabricating lies and
conspiracy theories about the last
election the one you didn't win that's
not how democracy's supposed to work let
me be very very clear about this barack
obama is not a good man i regret voting
for him i think maybe i said that once
before but i completely regret
voting for barack obama i should have
voted for john mccain and i should have
voted for mitt romney i ain't no mitt
romney fan
but everything he said there is a lie he
is a smug dishonest snake oil salesman
that's what he is first off republicans
don't want you to vote that's what he's
telling you
simply not true republicans want things
like voter id like they have in
virtually every civilized nation on
planet earth that you would show an id
when you vote much like you show an id
when you get on an airplane or perhaps
when you send a fedex package or when
you rent a hotel room or maybe when you
buy cigarettes or purchase a gun or open
a bank account or apply for food stamps
or welfare or when you apply for social
security or unemployment or when you
rent or buy a house
he's saying that they want to stop you
from voting but all they want to do is
secure our election system make sure
that people who are supposed to be
voting are voting make sure the people
who aren't supposed to be voting aren't
or can't vote twice etc etc so he's
absolutely lying about that then he says
that why don't they make the case why
don't they make the case for their ideas
actually
i would say republicans or conservatives
right leading people are making the case
for low taxes getting us out of war all
of the things that trump talked about
low black unemployment let's invest in
some of these communities let's not
nation build let's leave things to the
states now he does make a point um that
they've got to get their message out and
it's like well they do have trouble
getting their message out because you do
have all of the networks against you all
of the mainstream media against you and
you have big tech against you so i will
you know give him that it's like it's
tough to get the message out when you
can't um and he says if you've got good
ideas then good people will flock to you
well
again we have a lying media that just
won't let that happen by the way he went
on to say there was another clip that
was actually possibly even more
extraordinary than that endlessly smug
lie like this was the guy that was
supposed to heal us
man
awful but there's another clip where he
talks about how the republicans are only
in it for this fake culture war this
fake outrage war and it's like no that's
not true either man you know good decent
people who don't want their children
taught critical race theory don't want
them to be taught to judge people by the
color of their skin that's what they
don't want for their children it's like
that's not fake man you know making sure
that we all have access to platforms so
that we can speak freely is not fake
making sure that just because you have
some conservative or non-progressive
view you're not going to be booted off
everything or have your job taken away
is not fake fighting so that the
government can't inject you with
whatever it wants whenever it wants no
matter how many times it gets all the
information wrong in the first place is
not fake so he's just a liar he's just
dishonest he's a liar i regret voting
for barack obama i apologize to any of
you good mccain romney people out there
back at the time but you know you live
and learn